elon musk the world's richest man is now
trolling mcdonald's using dogecoin
literally this is laugh out loud funny
elon musk tweeted yesterday he said i
will eat a happy meal on television if
mcdonald's accepts dogecoin now of
course elon musk he said lots of things
about bitcoin he said lots of things
about dogecoin but this is a classic
troll just somebody who understands the
internet an absolute meme lord going
after one of the largest fast food
chains in the world and of course
mcdonald's they're not going to sit by
their unpaid social media intern jumping
into the fray very very quickly hitting
them with only of tesla except grimace
coin which is their little purple
character that's featured in a lot of
their marketing campaigns now ultimately
what is elon musk doing he's simply
trolling mcdonald's he's trolling the
dogecoin community he's also trolling
the larger world he understands that as
the world's richest man as the founder
or the ceo of both spacex tesla openai
and also neuroleague he understands that
when he talks people are going to pay
attention what's a great way to go ahead
and get people talking about dogecoin at
mcdonald's and elon musk well tweet
something like this i will eat a happy
meal on television if mcdonald's accepts
dogecoin i don't think mcdonald's is
actually going to end up accepting
dogecoin i don't think that mcdonald's
actually is going to end up accepting
cryptocurrencies any time soon what i do
think that mcdonald's should do is they
should go ahead and accept bitcoin they
should do that because that's ultimately
the asset that the majority of people in
the crypto community hold but of course
mcdonald's they're simply going to troll
if the meme lord is going to troll them
they're going to troll him right back
and so you got to give credit to
mcdonald's rather than sit there and
take this laying down rather than simply
blunder this awesome opportunity for
more free advertising and press
mcdonald's stepping in creating a fake
coin and automatically going right back
at him now elon musk eating mcdonald's
it's pretty funny if you're the world's
richest man in the world most people
think that you sit there eating caviar
and you're getting served and literally
fed grapes in your mouth like the old
king tut back in ancient times but
ultimately elon musk probably does eat
mcdonald's he probably does eat those
salty fries and when he goes to
mcdonald's and asks about the mcflurry
machines working everyone knows it's a
50 50 shot so elon musk tip of the cap
great troll maybe let's start spending
more time on bitcoin rather than focus
so much on dogecoin but mcdonald's
congrats on the free press and
ultimately when you got the world's
richest man going ahead tagging you and
promoting your business i think you're
doing something right what do you think
ultimate troll um this stuff is actually
pretty scary for people i think because
someone created the what is it the
grimace the coin and it went up 285 000
just based off mcdonald's response to it
it's it's absolutely crazy i think
elon's diluted his power behind dogecoin
and other cryptocurrencies throughout
the last few years um he recently used
to be able to say and it would move tens
of uh tens if not hundreds of percent
and now it moves like seven percent on
the news right so people know that he is
behind it a little bit um i'm not sure
what his marketing strategy is behind it
but um yeah it's just funny he's he's
trolling mcdonald's you uh uh one of the
things i think about with him is like
you have to take to john's point
everything he says about crypto uh he's
an incredible entrepreneur we talk about
this all the time right he's he's
solving some of the world's biggest
problems uh
kind of through entrepreneurship and
things that the private government
couldn't or that he's doing things
through the private kind of
infrastructure that the public
government couldn't do so ultimately i
think everyone wants him to succeed in
the things that he's attempting to do uh
but when it comes to crypto like it's a
completely different story he was
laughing like one of the things i
thought was funny the other day and you
can think nfts are stupid and worthless
and all this stuff it doesn't really
matter but he called out uh twitter he
said hey you guys spend you know
you spend hours of your engineers time
and all this stuff and all these
resources to get nfc profile pictures
like how about you clean up the bots in
my chat fair point but he also forget i
forgot to mention that uh he he spent
tesla's engineers time and their
developer time to go out and uh and
accept dogecoin as payment right so like
it kind of goes both ways he was pumping
on snl he's doing tweets like this like
i it's hard to say that he has the best
interest of people that are interested
in crypto in mind when he's doing these
things i think more of it is memeing and
trolling and doing all these things and
it's fun if you attack it in that way
but unfortunately i believe there's some
people that take it seriously right and
are not as educated on the space and
don't realize the
risk associated with investing in
something like that so ultimately like i
hope everyone sees it as a joke and has
fun with it and sees it as entertainment
because it is but ultimately you also
don't want people taking it the wrong
way and investing in dogecoin and saying
hey where are these returns i thought
this was similar to bitcoin or something
else like that
i agree i think that uh
it is what it is the meme lord is gonna
meme lord and that's what it is